Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Acht Spieltage sind in der 2. Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer gespielt. Höchste Zeit mal wieder draufzuschauen und ein paar Fragen zu stellen. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 181. Tja, und an wen will ich diese Fragen stellen? Mein Name ist natürlich Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und ich begrüße bei mir Pike vom 1912 FM Holstein Kiel-Podcast, einem der Podcasts, der schon seit seinem Bestehen eines der schönsten Podcast-Logos der deutschen Podcast-Landschaft hat. Hallo Pike. Also wirklich, ich bin großer Fan. Habe ich glaube ich auch irgendwo schon mal geschrieben, auf Twitter und so weiter, wer auch immer das entworfen hat. Weiß nicht, ob ihr das wart oder bekannte Freunde von euch. Richtig, richtig schönes Podcast-Logo. Musst du bitte weitergeben. Und ebenfalls mit dabei eine bekannte Stimme. Da werden jetzt Leute niederknien, dass sie ihn endlich auch wieder im Rasenfunk hören. Und nicht nur in einem seiner zahlreichen anderen Podcast-Formate bei meinem Sportpodcast, der eh Tobias Rieger. Da macht er unter anderem auch Hannover liebt, den Podcast Hallo, Tobi.
Oh, Max, das waren viele, viele nette Worte. Und ja, Hannover liebt, es pausiert gerade ein wenig, sagen wir mal so.
Ich hab mich noch gefragt, wie kündige ich das jetzt an? Aber ich wollte da... Ja, gut, aber man kann dich ja reichlich hören. Ich, ehrlich gesagt, bin einfach nur froh, dass wir jetzt nicht schon wieder über irgendwelche Eigentümerstrukturen bei Hannover 96 sprechen müssen. Das waren ja sonst so immer zuletzt die Themen, bei denen wir uns gesehen haben. Ihr hattet wieder irgendeine Mitgliederversammlung, irgendwas ist schief gelaufen, irgendwas Neues wurde bekannt über Martin Kind. Und dann haben wir da drüber gesprochen.
Dann lösche ich jetzt 17 Seiten Vorbereitung und wir können starten. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Alles gut, da passiert tatsächlich relativ wenig im Moment bei Hannover 96. Von daher, das passt schon.
Das muss ein ungewohntes Gefühl sein. Aber da kommen wir dann später zu. Also wir wollen auf Holstein, Kiel und auf Hannover 96 logischerweise einen Schwerpunkt legen in diesem Kurzpass. Und wir haben uns überlegt und hoffen, dass wir diesem Anspruch auch gerecht werden können, dass wir jetzt dann ansonsten in diesem Kurzpass über all die Zweitligisten sprechen, die im letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass nicht zur Sprache gekommen sind. Und wir gehen da in Reihenfolge der Tabelle durch und beginnen damit beim ersten FC Heidenheim. Der liegt auf Platz 3 mit 4 Siegen, 3 Unentschieden, nur einer Niederlage, 10 zu 6 Toren. Hat jetzt die letzten 3 Spiele in Folge gewonnen. Tobi, Heidenheim ist ein Dauergast in der 2. Liga. Man hat auch das Gefühl, da tut sich gar nicht so viel. Aber irgendwas muss sich ja verändert haben in all den Jahren. Warum stehen die schon wieder so gut da?
Die Antwort ist natürlich Frank Schmidt, der da, glaube ich, seit 14 Jahren, was wirklich sehr beeindruckend ist und was mich als Hannover 96-Fan auch ein bisschen neidisch macht, dass man so viel konstant auf überhaupt einer Position...
Ist das überhaupt erlaubt?
Darf man das überhaupt? Das ist natürlich der Grund. Wenn man sich anguckt, was die diese Saison gewechselt haben an Spielern, auch fast nichts. Das ist, glaube ich, die Mannschaft in der 2. Liga, die am wenigsten Veränderungen im Kader hatte. Ich fand, dafür sind sie ein bisschen holprig in die ganze Saison reingekommen. 0-0 gegen Paderborn, gegen den Aufsteiger Ingolstadt, der nun ganz hinten in der Tabelle steht, auch nur in Anführungsstrichen 2-1 gewonnen. Dann haben sie in Hannover sogar verloren. Ich erinnere mich dran, dass ich nicht so ganz genau wusste, wie das geschehen ist. Für uns war es damals unfassbar wichtig. Aber es ist so ein bisschen holprig noch in Heidenheim. Aber wenn man jetzt, du hast gerade gesagt, das ist die beste Mannschaft von denen, über die wir sprechen wollen. Ich war kurz überrascht, dass sie dann doch schon wieder dritter sind. Ja, es ist noch früh in der Saison und es ist alles nah beieinander mit 15 Punkten. Also ein Sieg weniger, bist du dann irgendwie nur noch neunter anstatt dritter, wenn du nur zwölf Punkte hast. Aber insgesamt Heidenheim ist einfach konstant, du hast es gesagt, dass das Team der 2. Liga, früher hat man glaube ich immer Sandhausen so rangezogen, wenn es um, ich möchte nicht in die 2. Liga, da muss ich nach Sandhausen fahren, wenn es darum ging. Jetzt ist es irgendwie Heidenheim und letzte Saison nur 8er gewesen. Das hat mich bei der Recherche ein bisschen überrascht. Ich hatte sie besser in Erinnerung, aber jetzt mit Platz 3. Ich glaube, sie machen sich da oben diese Saison wieder einigermaßen bequem.
Vor allen Dingen bei Heidenheim ist ja der Fall, dass man gar nicht wusste, wie die Saison verläuft, ohne einen Marc Schnatterer. Also das konnte man sich ja auch nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwann mal eintrifft, dass der nicht noch irgendwie mit dem Rollstuhl auf dem Platz gekarrt wird. Aber funktioniert anscheinend ganz gut. Haben ja auch mit Tim Kleindienst letzte Saison ja noch geliehen von Gent, jetzt für 3,5 Millionen gekauft, auch bester Torschütze mit drei Treffern. Also haben ihren Kader gut zusammen behalten, plus noch gut verstärkt und halt gerade defensiv stehen sie gerade sehr gut. Das ist ja beste Defensive der Liga. Gerade Oliver Hüsing macht da einen sehr, sehr guten Job. Also Respekt, also gute Arbeit auf jeden Fall.
Das läuft wieder alles ganz in geregelten Bahnen beim ersten FC Heidenheim. Kann man sich auch ganz gut angucken. Also es sind nicht die spektakulärsten Spiele, aber ich finde bei Heidenheim, das ist eine der Mannschaften, auch wenn sie mal zurückliegen sollten, kannst du davon ausgehen, die spielen weiter strukturiert nach vorne. Die rennen jetzt nicht kopflos an. Es gibt jetzt nicht irgendwie in den letzten 5 Minuten tausendlange Bälle nach vorne, sondern Heidenheim ist so eine Mannschaft, das läuft auf so einem konstant guten Level durch. An denen bleibe ich immer wieder hängen, was ein seltsamer Satz ist. Das fällt mir in der Sekunde, in der ich sage, selbst auf. Aber es ist so, ich kann nichts dafür. Es ist mein King.
Es ist auch ein Stück verdient, finde ich. Also wie gesagt, man quägt immer ein bisschen bieder und ein bisschen langweilig. Aber ich finde, es ist auch mindestens genauso beeindruckend, was die da seit Jahren leisten. Und ich finde, deshalb kannst du da auch öfter mal dran hängen bleiben und die Spiele von denen auch zu Ende gucken.
Danke, da fühle ich mich doch gleich ein bisschen besser. Das ist der 1. FC Heidenheim. Über den wir in der letzten Sendung auch nicht gesprochen haben, war der 1. FC Nürnberg. Das müssen wir jetzt natürlich nachholen. Denn die sind die einzige Mannschaft, die noch umgeschlagen ist in dieser 2. Fußball-Bundesliga. Der Männer 3-Siege, 5 Unentschieden, 11 zu 7 Tore. Das heißt, auch defensiv sind wir da in einer ähnlich guten Region unterwegs wie Heidenheim. Es ist eine fast identische Bilanz. 14 Punkte. Es scheint Pike ganz gut zu laufen beim Club.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe immer so, wenn ich deren Spiele gucke, gerade diese Saison, gar nicht so das Gefühl, dass es bei denen so gut läuft.
Das haben viele Club-Fans ehrlich gesagt auch nicht, die ich kenne.
Aber die Punkteausbeute stimmt auf jeden Fall. Und mit Mats Möller-Dehlin natürlich auch noch mal einen sehr, sehr spielstarken Mittelfeldspieler geholt, der auch, so wie ich das zumindest mitbekommen habe, eine relativ gute Saison spielt. Ansonsten habe ich mir so viel von denen noch nicht angeschaut. Jetzt das Spiel gegen die HSV war natürlich ein sehr, sehr gutes Spiel. Hätte ruhig noch länger gehen können. Ich finde, das war von beiden Seiten schön anzusehen, bzw. sehr ereignisreich.
2 zu 2 ging es aus für alle, diejenigen, die es nicht verfolgt haben.
Genau. Letzte Saison dann ja noch ein starker Manuel Scheffler. Da muss man natürlich auch noch mal gucken. Er war ja auch lange verletzt. Wie der jetzt noch mal so in die Saison findet, ich glaube, das ist noch mal ein wichtiger Stürmer für Nürnberg. Aber wenn sie so weitermachen, werden die, glaube ich, auch da oben erst mal bleiben, so in den Top 5.
Ja, ich finde, die Verpflichtung von Christopher Schindler hat auf jeden Fall geholfen, den haben sie von Hadersfield geholt. Der bringt für die Abwehr sehr, sehr viel rein. Wenn wir eben gesagt haben, dass Heidenheim die beste Abwehr der Liga hat, kommt dann danach auch schon Nürnberg mit sieben Gegentoren in acht Spielen. Und der bringt mit Asker Sörensson, oder vielleicht bringt der Asker Sörensson sehr viel Sicherheit und zusammenbringen sie dann einen eines der Top-Inn-Verteidiger, du es in der Liga, auf dem Platz, finde ich. Und das lässt sich relativ gut angucken. Sie sind, was das Umschaltspiel angeht, auch ziemlich stark, finde ich, haben dann natürlich das Problem, was jeder oder fast jeder Verein in dieser 2. Liga hat. Wenn sie den Ball haben, wird es ein bisschen schwierig. Dann damit produktiv umzugehen, ist nicht so ganz ihr Ding. Aber insgesamt, finde ich, spielt Nürnberg das sehr, sehr souverän und sehr, sehr unauffällig runter. Ich glaube, das war ja auch das, was eben gefallen ist. Man hat es gar nicht so ganz mitgekriegt, dass die auf einmal da oben stehen. Vielleicht noch einen Spieler rauspicken, der diese Saison mir sehr, sehr gut gefällt. Der kam, glaube ich, von Freiburg, Lino Tempelmann, spielt dort zentrales Mittelfeld, übrigens 1,74 Meter groß, drei Kopfballtore gemacht. Muss man auch erst mal hinkriegen. Und ist derjenige, der im Moment so ein bisschen der Player to watch ist, bei Nürnberg habe ich das Gefühl. Der zieht die Fäden, hat das Ganze im Griff und dann das Ganze zusammen mit Mats Möller-Dehli ist einfach im Moment eine, ja, ich weiß nicht, ist eine richtig gute Sache, die mir gefällt. Also wir fahren da jetzt nächste Woche hin, deshalb gefällt mir das grundsätzlich nicht so gut. Aber wenn man das neutral beobachtet, macht Nürnberg das schon nicht verkehrt im Moment. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Mannschaft, da ist ein bisschen Potenzial drin.
Enrico Valentini ist mir auch bei denen aufgefallen. Also klar hat natürlich auch die Führungsspieler-Anspruchsrolle als Kapitän, aber Außenspieler ist ja ein wichtiges Thema im gesamtdeutschen Fußball. Und da kann man ihn jetzt mit seinen 32 Jahren nicht mehr als junges Nachwuchstalent bezeichnen. Aber ich finde, der hat sowohl mit dem Ball als auch gegen den Ball schon viele gute Aktionen in dieser Saison gehabt. Und was meinem, aber jetzt halt aus der größeren Entfernung, Blick nach der Club in dieser Saison besser schafft, ist eben stabiler zu sein. Also der FCN war in der letzten Saison noch so, dass die von Spiel zu Spiel umfallen konnten. Es war sehr schwierig, die zu tippen. Es war relativ wild. Mal ein 0 zu 2, dann aber ganz souverän 3 zu 1 gewonnen. Und dieses Jahr, natürlich, wenn du nicht verloren hast, dann musst du irgendwie stabiler spielen, ist das alles in geordneteren Bahnen. Und dann glänzt da nicht alles. Also ich habe das Spiel gegen Rostock mit einem Auge verfolgt, das 1 zu 0. Also entweder lag es jetzt nur an dem einen Auge oder da gab es jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu verfolgen. Es ist nicht immer spektakulär, was Nürnberg macht, aber man fährt dann doch irgendwie sein, zieht seinen Fußball ganz gut durch und hat damit Erfolg. Und das finde ich halt auch mit Blick auf den Trainer Robert Klaus ganz interessant und auf die Strukturen da generell. Mit Dieter Hecking, also wenn wir jetzt schon manche Transfers gelobt haben, wenn wir sagen, die Spielweise scheint auch noch mal einen nächsten Entwicklungsschritt genommen zu haben, dann zieht das nach außen, von außen, wie etwas aus, das sich so langsam formt. Und so kann man dann auch mal aufsteigen.
Und das Ganze noch gepaart mit so einer angenehmen Bescheidenheit. Also du hast gerade Robert Klaus angesprochen. Ich habe ein bisschen geguckt, was er so die letzten Wochen und Monate gesagt hat. Nachdem der Saisonstart so gut gelaufen ist, hat er sich trotzdem sehr, sehr zurückhaltend geäußert, hat gesagt, wir sind kein Top-Team der zweiten Liga. Es gibt 10 Top-Teams in der zweiten Liga, hat er gesagt. Also man versucht das Ganze und Nürnberg hat sicherlich auch den Anspruch, langfristig vielleicht mal wieder in die erste Liga zu gucken. Du hast es gerade angesprochen, Dieter Hecking da, ein wichtiger Position, ist ja nun auch einer, der viel schon gesehen hat im Fußball. Es macht insgesamt, macht das einen soliden, sympathischen Eindruck, den Nürnberg da im Moment hinterlässt.
Meine Güte, ich glaube, so positiv wurde schon seit Jahren nicht mehr über den Club gesprochen im Rasenfunk. Aber freut mich sehr für alle Fans da draußen, die mal zuhören. Das ist nur für euch, liebe Leute. Ihr habt durchgehalten und jetzt läuft es endlich mal besser. Ich gönne es euch einfach, das sage ich jetzt einfach mal so. Ich habe auch viele Club-Fans in meiner Umgebung, kommen ja aus Mittelfranken. Wir müssen aber auch und wollen unbedingt über Dynamo Dresden sprechen. Die sind nämlich nicht so arg viel schlechter als der Club. Also generell, Tobi hat es ja schon angesprochen, alles sehr eng beieinander. Das wird auch in der zweiten Liga noch ganz lange so bleiben. Das ist uns allen klar. Das heißt, wir hängen uns jetzt nicht an den Tabellenständen auf, aber an der Bilanz der Punkte, da kann man sich ja orientieren. Da hat Dynamo Dresden auch 13 Punkte gesammelt, allerdings mit einer ein bisschen anderen Verteilung als der 1. FC Heidenheim und der 1. FC Nürnberg. Vier Siege, ein Unentschieden, drei Niederlagen. Das heißt, verkürzt gesagt, Hopp oder Top, in die eine oder die andere Richtung ging es. Pike, was ist dir bei Dresden bisher aufgefallen? Wie hat Dynamo das geschafft, diese gute Zwischenbilanz zu erreichen?
Erst mal ist mir aufgefallen, dass sie unglaublich effektiv sind. Die brauchen echt nicht viele Chancen, um ihre Tore zu erzielen. Da muss man gerade Christoph Daffener sagen, mit 8 Spielen jetzt 5 Treffer, 2 Vorlagen. Das ist schon richtig, richtig stark. Im Zusammenspiel mit Heinz Merchel zum Beispiel, der auch damals mal bei Kiel war oder Königsdorfer. Die Offensive hat gefühlt echt Spaß. Und das ist glaube ich gerade der Pluspunkt für Dynamo Dresden. Dass die halt gar keinen Druck haben im Endeffekt und gerade offensichtlich sehr locker und verspielt habe ich das Gefühl noch rangehen. Und defensiv sieht das ja auch ganz gut aus, mit nur 8 Gegentreffern. Also das ist glaube ich so diese Unbekümmertheit von einem Aufsteiger, der sich dann in so einem positiven Strudel spielt, sag ich mal. Ja und wenn du dann natürlich auch noch so ein Stadion hinter dir hast, da wird es dann auch für keinen Gegner leicht auswärts. Also die machen das schon richtig gut.
Ja und am letzten Wochenende haben sie das richtig gut gemacht gegen Werder Bremen. Ich meine, da war jetzt nicht zwingend mitzurechnen, dass sie 3 zu 0 gegen Bremen zu Hause gewinnen. War ein bisschen, du hast gerade gesagt, sehr, sehr effektiv, dass genau das waren sie. Da hatten nicht jetzt unendlich viele Chancen, aber machen halt alles rein. Bremen bietet auch relativ viel an. Haben da hinten teilweise verteidigt, wo ich dachte, oh, das haben sie sich ganz bestimmt bei Hannover 96 abgeguckt. Richtig, richtig gruselig. Aber das war beeindruckend. Wo man vielleicht ein bisschen aufpassen muss bei Dresden, ist jetzt die Verletzten, ja, das ist wirklich schon eine Misere. Also was da in Kreuzbanddresden rumläuft. Tim Knipping hatte sich, glaube ich, nach drei oder vier Spielen schon verletzt. Oder ebenheitlich nicht rumläuft. Genau, rumliegt wahrscheinlich im Moment eher. War richtig guter Innenverteidiger in den ersten Spielen. Den haben sie jetzt ersetzen müssen. Ich glaube, der zweite Torwart hat sich verletzt. Okay, Patrick Weihrauch hat sich verletzt. Jetzt im letzten Spiel, Panagiotis, da habe ich immer ein bisschen Schwierigkeit. Lachmar Demus, der links außen, hat sich verletzt. Auch Kreuzbanddres und Borello mit Mittelfußbruch noch oben drauf. Also da kommt eins zum anderen. Und wenn das jetzt mit der Effektivität vielleicht ein bisschen nachlässt könnte es, gerade die nächsten Spiele, St. Pauli, Nürnberg, Schalke, sehe ich jetzt nicht zwingend neun Punkte auf Dynamo Dresden zukommen. Und wenn es halt dumm läuft, ist es vielleicht auch nur einer. Und dann reden wir schon wieder über ganz, ganz andere Situationen, wenn der nächste Rasenfunk zur zweiten Liga aufgenommen wird.
Was man glaube ich noch mal positiv erwähnt kann, ist, die haben ja jetzt vor Bremen drei Spiele in Folge verloren. Und ich finde, das ist dann immer noch mal ein Zeichen, dass es trotzdem in der Mannschaft stimmt, wenn man dann doch noch mal wieder den 3-0-Grade gegen Bremen holt. Gut, Bremen ohne Toprak ist defensiv auch kaum vorhanden, aber trotzdem ist das für einen Aufsteiger immer noch mal ein gutes Zeichen, dass wenn man schon mal ein paar negative Erlebnisse hat, trotzdem zusammensteht, sag ich mal, und dann noch mal drei Punkte holen kann. Das ist schon viel wert.
Ja, und eben gerade die Heimstärke. Also es ist natürlich eine Binsel bei einer Mannschaft, die den Neumod resten, aber du kannst das halt nicht wegdiskutieren. Wenn neun der 13 Punkte zu Hause geholt wurden, dann ist das ein Argument und dann stimmt es mit den starken Gegnern, aber zum Beispiel zu Hause gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg, auch so positiv, wie wir Nürnberg besprochen haben. Es ist, glaube ich, für keine Mannschaft so wirklich angenehm, in Dresden zu spielen. Und das kann ein Pfund sein. Also es gibt ganze Mannschaften, Schalke, Entschuldigung, ich hatte Grafis im Hals, die hoffen nur deshalb, also mit dieser Heimstärke aufzusteigen. Also ist jetzt ein bisschen verkürzt, aber das ist ein wesentlicher Aspekt, den man eigentlich haben müsste. Zumindest war das, als dann der Abstieg feststand, das, was mir gegenüber dann viele Schalke-Fans gesagt haben. Na ja, aber die müssen ja dann alle auf die in die Arena kommen. Und dann wollen wir noch mal sehen, wie die dann gegen 50.000 spielen. Also, ja, bei den einen klappt es schon, bei den anderen noch nicht so. Aber ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gar nicht über Schalke sprechen. Das ist ja ein anderes Thema. Wir wollen stattdessen über den Hamburger SV sprechen. Den HSV haben wir das letzte Mal weggelassen. Und die spielen, tja, es tut ein bisschen weh, das zu sagen, aber es erfüllt schon wieder so manche Klischee-Muster, die sich in den letzten Zweitliga-Jahren etabliert haben. Es ist spektakulär. Es ist Tim-Weiter-Fußball. Es klappt auch manchmal ganz, ganz toll. Also das 1 zu 0 im Nordderby, im Nordderby, Nordderby, das war was anderes. Das war wunderbar. Das war für mich auch ein klassisches Tim-Weiter-Tor. Wie man dann den kompletten Sieg, dieses 2 zu 0 einordnet, das ist dann wieder eine ganz andere Frage. Da kamen viele Dinge zusammen. Aber das steht, finde ich, Tobi, schon so ein bisschen grundsätzlich für die Art und Weise, wie der HSV auch in dieser Saison schon wieder spielt. Es ist sehr wankelmütig. Man hat noch nicht häufig verloren, erst einmal. Das ist die gute Seite der Medaille. Die andere Seite der Medaille ist häufig in Rückstand geraten. Häufig musste man irgendwie ein Spiel noch aufholen. Jetzt erst wieder am Wochenende gegen Nürnberg ja auch ein 1 zu 2, das man noch zum 2 zu 2 gemacht hat. Sehr wilde Schlussphasen, mal positiv, mal negativ. Also der HSV ist so ein bisschen das Gegenteil von Nürnberg, wo wir gesagt haben, und Heidenheim ist, glaube ich, noch der bessere Gegenvergleich, wo wir gesagt haben, die cruisen so wie so ein Tanker durch diese 2. Liga. Da gibt es keine großen Ausschläge nach links und rechts. Der HSV ist wie ein EKG beim Kammerflimmern.
Ja, Nürnberg, Heidenheim, HSV haben ja auch alle eine Gemeinsamkeit, relativ viele Unentschieden. Und ich glaube, deshalb ist es dann auch immer schwierig, das so in eine Richtung zu gewichten. Holt man das Unentschieden nach dem Rückstand, verliert man noch zwei Punkte, indem man nach einer Führung dann noch Unentschieden spielt. Das sind alles so Sachen, die da so ein bisschen reinspielen. Und als ich mir das alles in Ruhe angeguckt habe, dachte ich mir, ach, so schlecht ist es beim HSV doch gar nicht. Und mein Gefühl war eher, dass diese Saison nicht so gut läuft. Diese eine Niederlage, du hast es eben angesprochen, die war natürlich ausgerechnet im Stadttherbie. Das darf man halt auch nicht vergessen. Das hat, glaube ich, insgesamt die Stimmung schon arg gedrückt. Aber es ist halt nur eine Niederlage. Und der Rest sind Siege und Unentschieden. Das heißt, so ganz schlimm kann es nicht sein. Aber wenn du gesagt hast, dass alles ein bisschen wild oder ein bisschen durcheinander, ja, das ist es tatsächlich. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass sie am Anfang nicht so ganz genau wussten, in welche Richtung es gehen sollte. Tim Walther hat es damit zwei Stürmern versucht, hat sich jetzt aber dann nach der DFB-Pokal-Pause in Anführungsstrichen fürs 4-3-3 dann entschieden und spielt jetzt vorne mit Kittel und Jatta über die Außen und Glatzel vorne. Und ich habe das Gefühl, das klappt zumindest vorne sehr, sehr gut. Hinten wiederum eher ein bisschen schwierig. Das ist ja Jugend forscht, was sie da im Moment machen. Die haben den Vuskovic geholt, glaube ich, zum Transferende. Der soll da in der Innenverteidigung mit Schönenlau wahrscheinlich spielen. Aber jetzt hat Jonas David viel gespielt, der ist 21. Vuskovic ist 19, also dementsprechend ist das hinten vielleicht auch alles nicht so hundertprozentig sattelfest, was da gerade noch passiert. Würde ich sagen, kann man noch verkraften, denn eine der Sachen, die wirklich auffallen, wenn man sich den Kader anguckt, da ist keiner über 30. Und das ist doch irgendwie was, was beim HSV positiv zu sehen ist, dass man nicht auf irgendwelche alten Recken zurückgreift, so von wegen der hat mal hochgespielt, der kann was, sondern man ist bereit, junge Spieler einzusetzen. Man ist bereit, auch vielleicht aus der zweiten Mannschaft noch dem einen oder anderen noch ein bisschen mehr Chancen zu geben, im Moment hält sich das noch in Grenzen. Aber ich finde, insgesamt ist der HSV auf den zweiten Blick irgendwie attraktiver als auf den ersten Blick diese Saison, auch wenn man sich das Spiel anguckt. Also Tim Walther versucht da ganz viel mit spielerisch, mit Ballbesitz zu regeln. HSV hat, glaube ich, 66 Prozent Ballbesitz. Das ist mit weitem, weitem Abstand vor dem zweiten in der Liga beeindruckend fast schon. Gut, machen jetzt nicht unendlich viel draus, aber zumindest versuchen sie es. Und das finde ich für den Zweitligisten erst mal eine Sache, kann man positiv sehen.
Ja, und 14 Tore ist ja auch gar nicht so wenig. Also ich wollte das auch gar nicht so negativ verstanden wissen. Es ist sehr gut, dass du das gleich so eingeordnet hast. Ich finde auch, der HSV ist eine Mannschaft, wenn man da über ein Spiel hin drüber kommt, auf jeden Fall hängen bleiben. Denn es wird auf jeden Fall was passieren, auch Gegentore, aber das ist halt auch Tim-Weiter-Fußball. Es ist sehr offensiv gedacht, auch wenn ich das Gefühl habe, ein bisschen, also es ist nicht mehr gleichzusetzen mit dem, was man schon gesehen hat unter ihm. Ich finde, es ist schon im Ballbesitz auch ein bisschen strukturierter und es schieben jetzt nicht mal alle nach vorne, sondern es gibt schon eine klare Rollenverteilung zwischen, wer hat jetzt einen offensiven Auftrag und wer sichert jetzt erst mal ab.
Und auch klassisch Tim Walther beim Spiel gegen Nürnberg nimmt Heuer Fernandes, der Torwart, einen Rückpass fast am Mittelpunkt vom Feld an. Das ist auch klassisch Tim Walther. Das war damals bei Kiel ja auch schon so, dass mit Kenneth Kronheim, der gerne mal am Mittelpunkt des Feldes gewartet hat, was da vorne so passiert. Also das ist typisch für Tim Walther.
Es klappt sehr gut, was die Offensive angeht. Also Glatzel hat schon 5 Tore gemacht, Moritz Heier hat schon 4 Tore erzielt generell, der HSV mit 14 Toren unterwegs. Wen gibt es denn, Pike, vielleicht jenseits von Offensivspielern, wo du sagst, die gehen vielleicht dann ein bisschen unter? Also jemand wie ich, der sieht dann eben vor allem die Tore und der sieht die Highlights-Szenen. Wer zieht denn so die Fäden im defensiven Bereich beim HSV?
Also auch wenn es mir natürlich weh tut, Jonas Meffert war schon ein sehr, sehr guter Transfer vom HSV.
Ich hab dir die Brücke dahin gebaut, weil ich vermutet hab, das ist die Antwort.
Genau, war ja schon bei uns jetzt letzte Saison einer der besten Sechser der Liga. Und ja, Tim Walter kennt ihn auch aus Kiel schon. Und gerade im Zusammenspiel mit David Kinzombie, der auch unter Tim Walter in Kiel seine beste Zeit hatte, finde ich, funktioniert das im Mittelfeld schon sehr, sehr gut. Klar, Tim-Walter-Fußball ist auch so ein bisschen, wir versuchen am Ende, ein Tor mehr zu schießen als der Gegner. Da fallen nun mal auch viele Gegentore. Aber das Mittelfeld, finde ich, hat er schon sehr, sehr gut hinbekommen mit Meffert, Kinzombie und auch einer der besten. Die Saison beim HSV ist natürlich Moritz Heyer, der eine sehr, sehr gute Saison spielt. Also wenn Tim Walter jetzt noch die Defensive richtig stabil kriegt, dann steht dem HSV, glaube ich, nichts mehr im Wege. Aber das schafft Tim Walter fast bei keinem Verein. Das liegt, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen an seinem Fußball einfach.
Ja, was für ein seltsamer Befund eigentlich. Und trotzdem würde ich sagen, also ich gucke den Hamburger SV sehr gerne aktuell, muss ich sagen. Mir macht das total Spaß. Ich bin ja generell jemand, der sagt, ich klatsche erstmal für jede Mannschaft, die sagt, wir wollen den Ball haben, weil mich das nervt, dass ganz viele deutsche Vereine Fußball spielen, wo sie sagen, Ball, was ist das bitte nicht? Wir wollen nur umschalten, was anderes wollen wir nicht machen. Deswegen, das finde ich schon immer gut. Ich finde, dass da auch der HSV tolle Druckphasen hat. Also gerade in den Heimspielen, wo man zurück lag, war das halt das, was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, auch bei Heidenheim. Das war ein strukturiertes Spiel nach vorne. Das war ein systematisches Passen rund um den 16er. Da sind ehrlicherweise dann auch manchmal wilde Aktionen mit dabei, aber auch einen positiven. Da gibt es dann mal Bakary Yata, gewinnt er mal ein Dribbling und dann geht er an die Grundlinie. Da ist immer was los. Ich finde den Hamburger SV, der ist gerade sehr gut anzusehen und gleichzeitig kann ich aber auch jeden Fan verstehen, der sagt, ein bisschen langweiliger dürfte es für mich auch sein, weil es halt auch in der Defensive ein bisschen wild ist. Nun ja, dann schauen wir mal, was wir dann später beim zweiten HSV so sagen werden, über die Art und Weise, wie gut oder schlecht man ihn angucken kann. Vorher wollen wir noch über den KS Ruhe SC sprechen. Damit sind wir auf Tabellenplatz 9 angelangt. 3 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen, 12 zu 9 Tore, 12 Punkte. Also eine relativ stabile Gesamtlage beim KSC, Tobi. Das sieht mir für mich recht ordentlich aus, nachdem man ja eigentlich fast so ein bisschen erwarten konnte, zu dem, was ich so mitbekommen habe, dass sich der KSC schwer tun würde jetzt in dieser Saison.
Hätte ich auch gedacht, aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, sie profitieren noch vom relativ geglückten Saisonstart. Sie haben in Rostock das erste Spiel für Rostock in der 2. Liga 3-1 gewonnen. Danach gegen Darmstadt. Die Älteren werden sich erinnern, Darmstadt hatte dieses große Problem mit Corona. Sie haben auch 3-0 gewonnen. Und diese 6 Punkte schleppen sie auch immer noch so mit. Also in den nächsten 1, 2, 3, 6 Spielen danach gab es halt auch nur noch ein Sieg. Okay, gegen Schalke schwierig einzuordnen, finde ich. Aber die anderen Spiele wurden halt nicht gewonnen. Es ist so ein bisschen schwierig mit Karlsruhe, habe ich das Gefühl. Diese Erwartung, die du hattest, dass es nicht so eine Bomben-Saison wird, hatte ich auch. Aber wenn man sagt, sie haben 2 Spiele verloren gegen Nürnberg und St. Pauli, das passiert auch anderen in dieser Saison. Wir haben besprochen, wie stark Nürnberg ist, St. Pauli ist auch gut. Also ich tue mich so ein bisschen schwer, mit Karlsruhe diese Saison richtig einzuschätzen. Sie haben halt mit Philipp Hofmann jemanden, der die Tore macht, wenn es nötig ist. 4 Stück bisher diese Saison. Ansonsten kann ich nicht so wirklich viel zu Karlsruhe sagen, außer dass sie genau das liefern, was sie so müssen. Also mein Punkt gegen Bremen und dann die Siege zum Auftakt. Es plätschert so ein bisschen daher. Vielleicht jetzt mit Regensburg als Tabellenführer, danach Aue als letzter, vorletzter, ziemlich weit unten drin. Zwei Spiele, die so ein bisschen die Richtung vorgehen. Wenn man da 4 Punkte holt, geht es in die eine Richtung. Ist es eher nur einer, sieht es eher schlecht aus.
Ja, Pike, was kannst du ergänzen zum KSC? Hört sich für mich so ein bisschen an, als wäre der KSC der Zweitligadurchschnitt. Besiegst du sie, bist du besser als Platz 9, verlierst du gegen sie, bist du schlechter als Platz 9.
Ja, aber im Endeffekt trifft das, finde ich, auch ganz gut zu. Aktuell ist irgendwie Karlsruhe der perfekte Durchschnitt. Und ja, Hofmann ist natürlich die Lebensversicherung von Karlsruhe. Also, dass sie den nicht verloren haben, ist sehr, sehr viel wert. Ich glaube, ohne ihn sehen sie sehr, sehr viel schlechter, standen sie sehr, sehr viel schlechter da. Und auch Choi aus dem Mittelfeld, der eine sehr, sehr gute Saison bisher spielt. Und ja, defensiv weiß man auch, was man da erwartet bei Karlsruhe. Die haben halt hohe Recken da stehen und mit hohen Bällen kann Karlsruhe richtig gut arbeiten, offensiv wie defensiv. Das ist so ein bisschen ihr Prunkstück, so hohe Bälle. Und ansonsten ist alles okay. Also wie schon gesagt wurde, mal gewinnt man, mal verliert man, aber irgendwie plätschert das so vor sich hin.
Ja, defensiv tatsächlich der KSC die viertwenigsten Schüsse in Richtung des eigenen Tores zugelassen. Klar, acht Spiele erst, muss man noch ein bisschen warten. Jetzt mit Jan Regensburg, da kommt dann eine Aufgabe. Aber das sieht schon alles sehr, sehr stabil aus. Wobei der Hinweis natürlich richtig war mit dem guten Saisonstart, der sich da noch so ein bisschen durch die Saison durchträgt. Das ist dann vielleicht bei der nächsten Mannschaft, über die wir sprechen wollen, nämlich Fortuna Düsseldorf, ein bisschen umgedreht. Da war der Saisonstart eher ein bisschen schleppend. Und jetzt hat man aus den letzten drei Partien hat man sieben Punkte geholt. Und wenn ich euch jetzt sage, insgesamt sind es elf Punkte, dann wissen wir, naja, da kommt jetzt viel aus den letzten Wochen. Da war es auch schon ein bisschen unruhiger, Tobi, hatte ich das Gefühl, eben aufgrund des Saisonstarts. Wie würdest du jetzt die Lage da einschätzen?
Absolut, das ist das Problem. Es war unruhig und diese sieben Punkte waren sowas von zwingend nötig. Und wenn man sich anguckt, gegen wen Düsseldorf diese Saison gewonnen hat, Ingolstadt, Aue, Sandhausen. Das sind die letzten drei. Das heißt, das, was zu gewinnen war, also was man wirklich gewinnen muss, um nicht in ganz, ganz große Probleme zu kommen, haben sie auch gewonnen. Also von daher, das ist erst mal soweit okay. Sie sind zu Hause schwach. Sie haben zu Hause zwei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Die holen die Punkte auswärts, was wahrscheinlich einfach daran liegt, dass sie gegen die eben genannten Mannschaften auswärts gespielt haben. Also verkorkster Saisonstart auf jeden Fall bei Düsseldorf. Ich finde es, es ist noch so ein bisschen, ein bisschen schwer einzuschätzen, was sie da im Moment machen. Also Rufem Henning, ich meine, der ist 34, der hat jetzt sechs Tore geschossen, ist immer noch der Leistungsträger da. Ist ein Kader mit 96 Spielern gespickt. Auch da gilt wieder, ob das so klug ist, weiß ich nicht. Mit ehemaligen 96 Spielern. Edgar Prip, Felix Klaus hatten sie, glaube ich, letzte Saison aus Wolsburg ausgeliehen, jetzt fest verpflichtet. Es ist alles, wirkt so ein bisschen uninspiriert und so ein bisschen, ach, ich weiß nicht, ich will nicht zu doll lästern, aber dolle ist es nicht, was Düsseldorf diese Saison macht, habe ich das Gefühl.
Ja, ich fand eigentlich die ersten zwei Spieltage, da sah das gar nicht so schlecht aus mit dem 2-0-Sieg gegen Sandhausen und dann ja wirklich mit der Finnish-Niederlage gegen Bremen. Das war ja in der 94. gleich Düsseldorf aus und in der 96. macht dann noch Bremen den Elfmeter rein. Aber da dachte man trotzdem, das ist gar nicht so verkehrt, mal gucken, was mit Düsseldorf so geht. Dann kam ja die Niederlage gegen Nürnberg, gegen uns, haben sie auch erst kurz vor Schluss den Ausgleich gemacht. Also war dann doch alles nicht so schön, der Start. Und Düsseldorf, da ist dann halt sehr, sehr schnell Unruhe drin, wenn es nicht läuft. Ich weiß auch nicht so genau, wie sie da rauskommen wollen. Gerade offensiv natürlich auch mit vielen Verletzten. Emanuel Ioha verletzt, Pledl und Kovnacki. Es wird nicht leicht. Und dann natürlich mit einem Transfer von Botzenik, von Feyenoord quasi geliehen, wo man auch eigentlich dachte, das ist ein richtig guter, der sollte da funktionieren. Aber ohne Rufenhennings ist trotzdem offensiv nichts los.
Was ja auch eine Qualität von Rufenhennings sein könnte.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber es ist halt, finde ich, gerade in der 2. Liga auch immer sehr schwierig, wenn man so extrem abhängig von einem Spieler ist. Und gefühlt ist Düsseldorf, ähnlich wie Karlsruhe, das total von ihrem Mittelstimmer.
Jetzt haben wir ordentlich draufgehauen. Ich würde vielleicht noch was Nettes sagen, oder was ein bisschen Einordneres. Der Trainer Christian Preusser, erste Station im Profifußball, war vor, glaube ich, bei Rot-Weiß-Erfurt und dann in der zweiten Mannschaft vom Sportclub Freiburg. Ist 37, das ist alles neu. Sicherlich eine sportliche Aufgabe, das in Düsseldorf anzufangen. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es in Düsseldorf nicht sonderlich ruhiger ist als z.B. in Hannover, was die Erwartung angeht. Von daher kann man ihm und der Mannschaft nur hoffen, dass da ein bisschen Vorsicht rangegangen wird und man ihm die Zeit gibt, die nötig ist. Es ist ja jetzt auch nicht voll dramatisch, weil sie, wie du gerade gesagt hast, die sieben Punkte jetzt geholt haben in den letzten drei Spielen, sieht es ja auch in der Tabelle wieder ganz gut aus. Ich hoffe für Düsseldorf, dass das in Ruhe aufgebaut werden kann und dann der Mannschaft und dem Trainer Zeit gegeben wird.
Ja, sehr gut, dass du diesen Einwand machst. Genau über Christian Preusser wollte ich nämlich noch sprechen, weil ich ihn eine sehr mutige Verpflichtung fand, ist der Aufstiegstrainer der zweiten Mannschaft vom SC Freiburg. Generell könnt ihr euch mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, mit dieser Mannschaft, die da im letzten Jahr aufgestiegen ist, beschäftigen und gucken, wo die jetzt alle spielen. Das ist wirklich ganz, als hätte man irgendwie eine Konfetti-Granate in ein Zimmer geworfen. Und über den kompletten deutschen Fußball haben sich jetzt einfach diese Talente, diese jungen Talente inklusive des Trainers verteilt. Fortuna Düsseldorf spielt auch einen Ballbesitz. Zentrierten Fußball hat aber, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen mit der Herangehensweise ihrer Gegner zu tun. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Ich glaube, man wäre nicht so kritisch bei acht Spielen erst für einen neuen Trainer bei seiner ersten, richtigen Profi-Station, wenn es eben nicht Fortuna Düsseldorf wäre. Also das ist, glaube ich, der genau richtige Einwand, den du da gebracht hast, Tobi. Dementsprechend sollten wir es dann vielleicht dabei auch bewenden lassen. Und dann über den SV Darmstadt 98 sprechen, Pike. Die stehen ebenfalls mit elf Punkten da. Ebenfalls drei Siege, zwei unentschieden, drei Niederlagen. Entschuldigung, ich bin in der Zeile verrutscht. Eine, ein Unentschieden und vier Niederlagen. Ich dachte mir doch noch. Darmstadt nicht auch immer mal wieder auch in einiger... Also bei Darmstadt ist auch immer was los. Das kann man, glaube ich, auch so sagen. Und bei denen tue ich mich komplett schwer, das einzuordnen. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, haben sie mich am Anfang der Saison überrascht positiv. Und dann haben sie wieder so gespielt, wie ich eher davon ausgegangen bin, dass sie spielen würden, völlig seltsame Spiele. Und für mich dann fast unmöglich, das einzuordnen. Deswegen bin ich froh, dass du das jetzt machst.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich glaube, Darmstadt kann sich selber nicht so richtig einordnen aktuell. Auch hier natürlich wichtige Spieler von der letzten Saison verloren. Ganz klar Serdar Dursun, der beste Stürmer der letzten Saison, ist gewechselt. Sogar Ablösefrei, Victor Palsson ist zu Schalke gegangen. Das sind natürlich dann schon wichtige Spieler. Als Ersatz wurde dann ein Philipp Tietz geholt, vom WN Wiesbaden, wo man auch dachte, ist das jetzt wirklich der Serdar Dursun-Ersatz? Aber er macht das richtig gut.
Er ist es? Ja, er ist es.
Sechs Tore, wirklich eine starke Saison. Matthias Honsack spielt noch mal eine Ecke besser als letzte Saison. Benjamin Goller von Bremen Gelin ist auch ein Spieler, der gute Leistung zeigen kann. Der ist dann noch so ein bisschen wechselhaft. Aber insgesamt ist es bei Darmstadt sehr, sehr schwer, weil sie Spieler haben, wo man denkt, alter Schwede, das ist richtig guter Fußball, das ist schön anzusehen, schnell, offensiv. Sie haben ja auch die Saison unter anderem 6-1 Ingolstadt, 4-0 Hannover, und dann haben sie aber auch Niederlagen, 2-1 gegen Rostock, wo man auch denkt, das muss eigentlich nicht sein als Darmstadt. Auch Thorsten Lieberknecht als Trainer ist halt auch irgendwie so eine Wundertüte, ob das funktioniert oder nicht. Bei Darmstadt ist es aktuell noch in Ordnung. Ich meine, unter Markus Anfang letzte Saison war es ja ähnlich, da war die Hinrunde relativ schwach und dann haben sie ja die beste Rückrunde der Vereinsgeschichte gespielt. Also Darmstadt ist da auch so ein Verein, den man irgendwie nie abschreiben darf, die immer irgendwie für ein gutes Spiel da sind.
Ja, ist tatsächlich so. Ich glaube, das ist das klassische Darmstädter Winterloch. Also die haben immer so ab November, Dezember…
Ist bei denen ja schon Winter?
Bei denen ist dann immer schon Winter und dann hinten raus sind sie nochmal stark. Ja, diese Dursum-Geschichte ist natürlich eigentlich das alles umfassende Thema bei Darmstadt. Der hat letzte Saison 27 Tore gemacht und 6 Vorlagen. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Es gab vielleicht Gründe, warum der eine oder andere Trainer aus der 2. Liga den gerne bei seinem Verein gesehen hätte. Grüße an Kenan Kocsak. Und du hast es angesprochen, sie versuchen es jetzt mit zwei Stürmern, aus einem Stürmer machen sie zwei Stürmer, Philipp Tietz und Luca Pfeiffer, zusammen 9 Tore geschossen. Aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass davon zum Beispiel 4 allein in diesem Art of Freaking 6 zu 1 gegen Ingolstadt waren. Und genauso sind von diesen 15 Toren, die Darmstadt geschossen hat, was auf den ersten Blick sehr gut aussieht, das muss man erst mal hinkriegen in der Liga, sind 10 Tore gegen Ingolstadt und Hannover 96 gefallen. Also ist noch so ein bisschen unwuchtig verteilt, die ganze Geschichte. Und deshalb sieht es dann halt am Ende auch so aus, dass sie zwölfter sind, 10 Punkte. Ist nichts so richtig Greifbares, zu Hause stark, drei Siege auswärts eher schwach, drei Niederlagen, kein Sieg, ist alles noch ein bisschen früh in der Saison, aber das deutet im Moment schon mal so ein bisschen in eine Richtung. Vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz zum Trainer, Thorsten Lieberknecht, alter Braunschweiger. Ich glaube, wenn einer in Darmstadt richtig gut angekommen ist, dann er. Also der scheint sich sehr mit Darmstadt zu identifizieren, lebt das sehr, wird glaube ich auch sehr, sehr gut angenommen von den Fans und auch von der Mannschaft. Und ich glaube, das könnte ein Faktor sein für eine ruhige Saison, also keine Saison ganz oben, aber zumindest eine, die nichts mit Abstiegskampf oder Ähnlichem zu tun hat.
Ja, es steht und fällt so ein bisschen mit der Chancenverwertung, das ist häufig im Fußball so. Aber wenn ich euch sage, dass Darmstadt auf Rang 4 ist in der Verwertung ihrer Torschüsse, also dass die Schüsse auch tatsächlich zu Toren führen, hinter Paderborn auf 1, Regensburg und St. Pauli auf 2 und 3 und dann kommt schon Darmstadt, dann sieht man, also man hat es zum einen geschafft, Dorson zu ersetzen, auch mit der taktischen Umstellung, die ihr schon erwähnt habt. Gleichzeitig ist es aber auch sehr, sehr notwendig gewesen, plus wir müssen noch ein bisschen Freak-Spiel abziehen, dieses Ingolstädter 6 zu 1. Also Darmstadt, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, über Darmstadt werden wir noch häufiger in diesen Kurzmessen reden und bin gespannt, wie sehr sich da Fragezeichen in Ausrufezeichen umwandeln werden. Da muss ich dann vielleicht auch mal eine Expertin oder einen Experten aus Darmstadt hierher einladen. Aber jetzt habe ich ja einen Experten unter anderem zu Hannover 96 hier. Und Tobi, jetzt schaue ich mir Hannover 96 an. Und dann stehen die da mit 10 Punkten auf Tabellenplatz 13. 3 Siege, 1 Unentschieden, 4 Niederlagen. Und ich folge sehr vielen Hannover 96-Fans auf Twitter und es ist, da hat sich einfach ein Sarkasmus breit gemacht. Gegen den hat keine neue Trainerverpflichtung, kein Zwischenhoch hat er irgendwie eine Chance. Man muss einmal aufpassen, Twitter ist ja nicht das wahre Leben, ist vielleicht nicht ganz repräsentativ. Deswegen musst du mir jetzt helfen. Wie ernst ist die Lage bei Hannover 96 schon wieder?
Twitter ist auf jeden Fall nicht repräsentativ. Deshalb folge ich nicht so vielen Hannover 96-Fans, um mir da nicht auch noch das zweite Mal die Laune verderben zu lassen. Max, ich hab befürchtet, dass ich das hier tun muss, dass ich das erklären muss, aber ich kann's nicht. Im Moment kann ich dir nicht sagen, was bei uns los ist. Wir haben vielleicht als Rückgriff auf Fortuna Düsseldorf das gleiche Problem, dass wir eine mutige Trainerentscheidung getroffen haben. Jan Zimmermann war in der vierten Liga, der ist mit dem TSV Havelser aufgestiegen in die dritte Liga. Das ist wieder einer aus Hannover, aus dem Umfeld. Da hat man dann gerne und leicht zugegriffen. Aber das ist auch ein guter Typ, gar keine Frage. Der moderiert das im Moment auch alles sehr gut. Diese schwierige Situation mit Niederlagen, die absolut nicht verständlich sind. Wir haben vorhin schon über Darmstadt gesprochen, dass die 4 zu 0 zu Hause gegen uns gewonnen haben. Mit der Niederlage in Dresden. Wir haben zu Hause, am zweiten Spiel, da haben wir zu Hause 3 zu 0 gegen Hansa Rostock verloren. Und auch da, Rostock hatte das erste Spiel zu Hause auch verloren. 3 zu 1 gegen, jetzt habe ich es vergessen, wir haben vorhin darüber gesprochen. Also es gibt so viele Sachen, die man sich absolut nicht erklären kann. Dafür dann die Siege gegen Heidenheim und St. Pauli. Im Moment ist es nicht greifbar, wenn wir versuchen, es irgendwie an der Mannschaft aufzubauen oder sich daran zu orientieren. Wir haben ganz, ganz viele neue Spieler, also wirklich ganz, ganz viele. Im Vergleich zur letzten Saison hat sich da ganz viel getan. Die Innenverteidigung hat mit Boerner einen neuen gekriegt. Im Moment spielen wir auf dem rechten Verteidiger mit dem und nicht mehr mit Simon Royer. Das war auch schon anders diese Saison. Ondua und Ernst und Kerk als Mittelfeld ist komplett neu. Bayer, den wir ausgeliehen haben von der TSG Hoffenheim, der mir richtig gut gefällt, richtig guter Boker auf der rechten Bahn. Links, meiner, das ist noch mal einer, an den wir uns erinnern. Und vorne relativ verloren und verlassen, würde ich sagen, Lukas Hinterseher, dem es nicht viel besser geht als Mavud Dutsch letzte Saison, da kommt wenig hin in die Zentrale. Also, die Probleme sind oft die gleichen. Das Personal ist sehr weit ausgetauscht, habe ich das Gefühl. Es funktioniert aber noch nicht so hundertprozentig. Also, ich finde, wir spielen besser als letzte Saison, aber nicht so, dass wir da auch viel mitnehmen. Wir können da gerne vielleicht das Spiel gegen Sandhausen vom letzten Wochenende nehmen, wo wir wirklich eine gute erste Halbzeit gespielt haben. Die Sonne hat geschehen, wir haben da gesessen, wir waren grundzufrieden. Es hat Spaß gemacht, der Spielaufbau hat funktioniert, wir haben den Ball nach vorne gekriegt, wir haben zweite Bälle gewonnen, wir haben umgeschaltet. Es hat einfach alles funktioniert. Gehst 0-0 in die Halbzeit, verlierst das Spiel 2-1, weil der Torwart zwei Fehler macht. So was, das jetzt ein bisschen einfach formuliert, für die, die es gesehen haben, beim ersten Tor war es der Torwart mit einem Verteidiger, beim zweiten war es dann nur noch der Torwart. Das sind dann so Sachen, da versaust du dir dann halt auch deinen guten Lauf. Wie gesagt, gegen St. Pauli gewonnen, in Kiel gewonnen, 3-0, das war schon wieder alles gut und zum Anfassen. Und dann nimmt man es dir doch wieder weg, weil du zu Hause 2-1 gegen St. Hausen verlierst. Es ist so frustrierend und es ist schwer im Moment mit Hannover 96, Max.
Okay, also wenigstens die Konstante ist geblieben. So richtig leicht war es ja schon ganz lange nicht mehr mit 96. Du hast schon angesprochen das Problem in der Offensive, was jetzt auch kein neues Thema ist, was jetzt quasi auch mit neuem Trainer immer noch da ist. Wie groß ist denn dieses Problem, wenn man mal hinter die Reihen Ergebnisse blickt, also eben die Spiele auch sieht? Denn wenn ich mir zum Beispiel genau die Tabelle der Chancenverwertung, wo Darmstadt 98 auf Rang 4 liegt, da liegt Hannover 96 auf Rang 17. Man hat nur 4,4% seiner 158 Torschüsse umgewandelt in Tore, erst 7 Tore erzielt. Und diese 158 Torschüsse, das ist ein sehr guter Wert. Also damit liegt man auf Rang 9 in der zweiten Liga. Da könnte man jetzt auch sagen, Pech kommt mit rein oder ist die Qualität der Abschlüsse nicht gut genug, liegt es am Spielsystem, wo würdest du da ansetzen?
Na, ich mach's mir leicht und schieb's auf Pech. Also ja, wir haben viele Chancen und ja, es sieht besser aus als letzte Saison und wir spielen auch einen besseren Fußball, hab ich das Gefühl. Aber du musst die Dinge halt reinmachen. Und da fehlt es halt wirklich an der einen oder anderen Stelle im Moment noch. Und es macht irgendwie, ja, es macht schon mal schon sehr unglücklich. Und man könnte ja sagen, es liegt am Stürmer oder wie auch immer. Lukas Hinterseher ist ja damals in Hamburg auch nicht wirklich glücklich gegangen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es an ihm liegt. Er kriegt einfach keine Bälle oder so gut wie keine. Er wird zu wenig angespielt. Die meisten gefährlichen Tor-Szenen kommen von solchen Leuten wie Kerg und Ernst, also von dem 8er, von dem 10er, die dann zweite Bälle aufs Tor bringen. Und vielleicht ist das dann das Problem, dass wir von zu weit wegschießen und nicht in den Strafraum direkt reinkommen, um die einfachen Tore zu machen. Das ist das, was uns so ein bisschen fehlt diese Saison. Ich hoffe, dass wir das noch verbessern. Ich sehe allerdings, wenn ich unser Personal angucke, jetzt auch wenige Spieler, die da noch den entscheidenden Input geben können. Also Florian Muslia ist bei uns immer wieder einer, der seit Jahren unter dem spielt, was wir erwarten. Wir erwarten den Zauberfuß, der uns das Spiel lenkt und leitet und die geilen Pässe in die Schnittstellen spielt. Und auf einmal steht der Stürmer vorne frei. Das passiert aber nicht. Es wird gefummelt und es wird dabei verloren. Und all solche Geschichten, das ist, glaube ich, jetzt die vierte oder die fünfte Saison, in der das so ist mit ihm. Ich weiß nicht, es fehlt einen Moment an der entscheidenden Idee, wie wir den Ball vorne irgendwie Richtung Elfmeterpunkt kriegen, dass die einfachen Tore gemacht werden können und nicht immer alles über den zweiten Ball geht und mit fernen Schüssen, was wir an fernen Schüssen gehabt haben. Ich weiß nicht, wenn ich abends im Bett liege, dann sehe ich so hintereinander geschnitten 15 Schüsse aus 20 oder weiter 20 Metern oder weiter Entfernung, die mich dann doch nachts um den Schlaf bringen.
Tobi, such dir, bitte such dir Hilfe. Ich hatte das mal mit Flanken. Es ist behandelbar.
Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht so das Drama bei uns, Flanken. Dann wären wir ja schon in der Nähe vom Elfmeterpunkt, wenn wir mal flanken würden.
Und wie ist jetzt dann gerade die Gemengelage, was die Stimmung angeht in Hannover 96? Also wir wissen natürlich, Martin Kind steht dahinter. Wir wissen auch, dass es in der Fanszene auch durchaus verschiedene Lager schon immer gab. Ich hatte das Gefühl von außen betrachtet, dass die Trainerentscheidung positiv aufgenommen wurde, weil es mal etwas anderes war, weil man ins Risiko gegangen ist. Und man kann sich ja auch nicht ganz von dem Fakt lösen, wenn man einen neuen Trainer bekommt, von dem man de facto kaum etwas gesehen hat, bis gar nichts. Dann kann man sich alles vorstellen, das ist was anderes, als wenn du André Schubert als Trainer bekommst. Da hast du eben sofort, weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wie ich auf dieses Beispiel komme, dann hast du halt sofort andere Stationen vor Augen. Wie ist denn gerade die Lage in Hannover vom Umfeld her?
Also das ist auf jeden Fall positiv gewesen, dass es eben nicht André Schubert oder eine aus dieser Zweitliga-Trainer-Tausch-Gang geworden ist, sondern mal jemand Neues. Das wurde auf jeden Fall positiv aufgenommen. Da hat glaube ich wirklich keiner was Schlechtes zugesagt. Die Fanszene, die aktive Fanszene ist im Moment sehr ruhig, weil sie nicht im Stadion ist. Das ist ja bei vielen Vereinen noch so. Wir haben glaube ich am 1.10. ist jetzt wieder ein Treffen, wo überlegt wird, wie unter den neuen Corona-Gegebenheiten gegebenenfalls zurückgekehrt wird in Stadion oder halt auch nicht. Das wird man sehen, was da rauskommt. Dementsprechend ist dieser, es wird im Stadion Martin Kind muss weggerufen, Teil fällt aus im Moment. Das beruhigt das Ganze einigermaßen, weil das ja wirklich schon sehr, sehr unangenehm war, wenn dann die eigenen Fans Martin Kind weggerufen haben, die andere Hälfte der eigenen Fans dann gefiffen haben und die Mannschaft auf dem Platz gestanden hat und gesagt hat, warum wird denn jetzt gefiffen? Also das hat lange Zeit für viel Unruhe gesorgt, ist im Moment aber kein Thema, weil es zu diesen Rufen so gut wie gar nicht kommt. Stimmung? Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist tatsächlich im Moment noch so, dass man noch so ein bisschen den Kredit gibt, gerade weil es ein neuer Trainer ist, weil viele neue Spieler da sind, weil noch nicht alle Spieler tatsächlich spielen. Also wir haben natürlich dann auch wieder ganz Weltklasse hingekriegt, Tom Tribull zu verpflichten, der sich dann mit Corona direkt infiziert hat, bevor es richtig losgehen konnte. Also da ist noch so einer in der Pipeline, wo wir hoffen, dass der vielleicht noch die Mannschaft ein bisschen nach vorne bringen könnte im defensiven Mittelfeld. Bringt nicht viel nach vorne, aber zumindest für hinten ein bisschen Ordnung. Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie lange das ruhig bleibt. Also ich habe gerade gesagt, Ron-Robert Ziele hat gegen Sandhausen zwei dicke Böcke oder einen dicken Bock und einen mittelschweren Bock gemacht, war aber dann tatsächlich derjenige, der nach dem Spiel von den Fans persönlich erwähnt wurde und angefeuert wurde oder wie auch immer. Man hat ihm gezeigt, dass die Sympathien noch da sind. Also es ist nicht alles schlimm, zumindest nicht wenn man im Stadion ist und sich das dort anguckt. Ich hoffe, dass es noch ein bisschen so bleibt, aber wenn wir vielleicht auf die nächsten drei Gegner gucken können, also nicht, dass ich das gerne mache, aber nach Nürnberg, zu Hause gegen Schalke, nach Regensburg. Also auch da gilt, in drei Spieltagen wissen wir sehr, sehr viel mehr. Das kann halt ziemlich bitter werden oder vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm. Keine Ahnung.
Ach, ja, es ist immer ein unzufriedenstellender Befund, wenn man so sagt, wah, schwierig, wohin sich das entwickelt. Aber so ist es bei vielen Mannschaften, vor allem nach acht Spieltagen. Wie bewertest du denn die bisherige Arbeit der sportlichen Führung? Also wir haben ja Markus Mann als Sportdirektor unter anderem. Wir haben Jan Zimmermann als neuen Trainer. Michael Tanner tut noch als Leiter der Nachwuchsakademie rum. Weiß nicht, welchen Einfluss er hat bei Hannover 96. Aber wie bewertest du die Rolle der Genannten?
Erst mal spannend, dass die Reihenfolge war. Erst der Trainer, dann der Manager. Das ist nicht so ganz gewöhnlich. Ja, angeblich hatte man mit Markus Mann schon lange gesprochen. Und er hat da wohl schon, bevor er offiziell verpflichtet wurde, vielleicht das ein oder andere Wörtchen mitgeredet. Das weiß ich nicht. Aber grundsätzlich ja nicht die einfachste Konstellation, wenn es so geht. Aber die beiden machen, was für Hannover durchaus untypisch ist, einen sehr harmonischen und geschlossenen Eindruck. Und das freut mich persönlich dann ja immer, wenn es nicht so leicht ist, die beiden auseinanderzubringen, wie es zum Beispiel bei Kotschak und Zuba in der letzten Saison war, wo halt offen klar war, dass die beiden sich am besten gar nicht miteinander reden. Und wenn es sein muss, redet man ein bisschen übereinander. Mehr dann aber auch nicht. Markus Mann, ich finde das ganz gut, was er gemacht hat bisher. Also hat er Spieler verpflichtet, wir haben sie eben schon angesprochen, die eigentlich einzeln betrachtet Momente einen ziemlich guten Eindruck hinterlassen. Also Julian Burner in der Innenverteidigung von Sheffield Wednesday. Ich finde, so einen brauchst du in der 2. Liga, wenn du nicht auf Jugend vorstellst, brauchst du halt so einen 30-jährigen Erfahrenen, der das da hinten einfach locker wegspielt. Und das tut er, das macht er gut. Sebastian Kerg noch ein bisschen schwierig, der kam ja von Osnabrück. Weiß ich noch nicht genau, ob ich mit dem so ganz glücklich bin, im Gegensatz zu Sebastian Ernst, der von Fürth kam, der nicht mit Fürth aufgestiegen ist, der freiwillig nach Hannover gegangen ist. Auch eine Geschichte, weiß ich nicht, ob er da in 15 Jahren noch so entspannt drüber gucken kann, dass er gesagt hat, ach, das Bundesliga schenke ich mir, ich gehe lieber nach Hannover. Macht aber gut hier, gefällt mir. Gael Ondua, nicht Infanteiliger, defensives Mittelfeld, unser eigentlich im Moment einziger Sechser, auch wenn es immer ein bisschen anders aussieht auf den Aufstellungen, ist auch so einer, der ein bisschen Ruhe reinbringt, aber oft auch ein bisschen lässig aussieht. Also weiß ich noch nicht ganz genau, ob wir den da so alleine rumturnen lassen können. War auch übrigens derjenige, der beim 1 zu 0 von Sandhausen dann das Abseits aufgehoben hat und nicht hinten rausgelaufen ist. Also da sind ein paar Verpflichtungen mit dabei. Wie gesagt, Tom Tribull, müssen wir mal gucken, was aus ihm wird. Yannick Dehm spielt im Moment rechter Verteidiger. Den haben wir von Holstein Kiel geholt. Ich glaube, der wollte da auch nicht mehr bleiben, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Und insgesamt, finde ich, hat Markus Mann mit den, und das muss man immer in Hannover dazu sagen, wirklich begrenzten finanziellen Mitteln. Ja, ja, große Stadt und viel Potenzial. Aber was hier diese Saison an Geld ausgegeben werden durfte, das war wirklich, wirklich wenig. Und da muss man dann auch Markus Mann mal loben. Daraus hat er in meinen Augen, zumindest was die Einzelspiele angeht, nicht schlecht gepickt.
Markus Mann kam von der TSG aus Hoffenheim, war da im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum aktiv oder in der Akademie. Und habe ich die Reihenfolge noch richtig im Kopf. Deswegen habe ich es nämlich auch so rum genannt. Jan Zimmermann wurde doch schon als neuer Trainer präsentiert, bevor man wusste, dass Markus Mann der neue Sportdirektor werden würde.
Man hat erst Jan Zimmermann präsentiert. Den musste man ja da so ein bisschen vom Aufsteiger wegholen. Vielleicht bevor es jemand anderes macht. Ich weiß es nicht. Da hat mit Haves halt wirklich große Aufmerksamkeit erregt. Und ja, ich sage mal so, er war auch nicht das erste Mal im Gespräch. Also in Hannover wackelt der Trainer ja auch das öfteren Mal. Und ich glaube, letzte Saison gab es auch einen Spieltag, irgendwie so 5, 6 Spieltage vor Schluss, wo es hieß, Kena Kocsak ist weg. Der wird jetzt heute entlassen. Dann hat man aber nur bekannt gegeben, dass er zum Saisonende entlassen wird. Auch so eine ganz unangenehme Situation für den Beobachter. Und auch da und auch schon vorher hieß es immer mal wieder, Jan Zimmermann, das ist doch einer, der ist im Gespräch mit 96, da geht was. In dem Fall hat man sich ihn jetzt dann geschnappt relativ früh nach Saisonende. Und Markus Mann hat man ein bisschen später dazugeholt. Ja, ich glaube, das ist das ist erstmal okay. Die beiden, das passt zusammen. Und Markus Mann vielleicht noch einen, den ich vorhin schon leicht angelobt habe. Und jetzt gerne noch mal komplett mit Lob überschütten würde. Maximilian Bayer, den hat Markus Mann von Hoffenheim mitgebracht, hat gesagt, du brauchst Spielzeiten, die kriegst du in Hannover. Und die kriegt er auch. Und die kriegt er mit jeder Minute. Tut er etwas Gutes für Hannover 96. Was für ein guter Kicker. Also der ist 18, kommt aus, ich glaube, Cottbus nach Hoffenheim, hat dort die U-Mannschaften durchlaufen und hat dann jetzt das eine Jahr, leider nur ein Jahr und leider ohne Kaufoption, den Weg nach Hannover gefunden. Aber das ist ein geiler Boker. Auf den habe ich wirklich Bock diese Saison. Ich hoffe, der bleibt gesund und vielleicht bietet sich es sich ja noch an, dass man in der nächsten Saison vielleicht noch mal ein Jahr ausleihen könnte. Maximilian Bayer, merkt euch den.
Das ist ein guter Mann. Kritiziert mir den nicht zu viel. Das ist ein guter Mann. Also so ist die Situation bei Hannover 96. Im direkten Tabellenumfeld zu Hannover 96 liegt Holstein-Kiel. Aber da sind Pike die Themen ein bisschen anders, über die wir sprechen müssen. Wir müssen auch über den Trainer sprechen. Aber da haben wir einen der ersten Trainer-Abgänge. Ole Werner ist nicht mehr Trainer von Holstein-Kiel. Wie kam es denn bitte dazu?
So genau weiß das eigentlich noch niemand. Also Ole Werner ist freiwillig zurückgetreten nach dem Hannover-Spiel, wo ich aber auch klar sagen muss, dass ich nicht glaube, dass es jetzt an dem Hannover-Spiel lag oder dass das der ausschlaggebende Punkt war. Ich halte Ole Werner für einen sehr selbstreflektierenden Trainer, für einen sehr emotionalen Trainer und auch einen Trainer, der sehr auf sich, seine Psyche und seinen Körper und Co. hört. Der hat ja auch schon mal eine Auszeit bei Kiel sich genommen, die er einfach brauchte und er hat ja nach der sehr erfolgreichen letzten Saison seinen Vertrag auch nicht direkt verlängert, sondern hat um Zeit gebeten und hat jetzt gesagt, dass die Akzente und die Sachen, die er dem Kader mitgeben wollte, nicht so funktionieren und nicht den Erfolg haben, die er sich hofft und dass er deswegen oder dass das einer der Gründe ist, warum er zurücktritt. Es ist natürlich immer schwierig, was nach außen transportiert wird und was nicht. Also ich schätze ihn nicht so ein, dass er jetzt, was auch viele sagen, in Anführungsstrichen das sinkende Schiff verlässt oder so, da so einer ist, Ole Werner, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob da noch was rauskommt, was der genaue Grund ist. Ich glaube, man wird es erst wissen, wenn auch Ole Werner selber darüber spricht. Aber ich habe persönlich das Gefühl, dass es nicht unbedingt was Sportliches ist.
Er hat einen wunderbaren Satz gesagt, wirklich einen Satz, der Gänsehaut macht. So habt ihr euch auch eure letzte Folge genannt. Euer Trainer sein zu dürfen, war mehr, als ich je vom Fußball erwartet habe.
Ja, da habe ich auch immer noch Gänsehaut und Tibi in den Augen. Das war sie als erster Kieler, hat damals für Kiel gespielt, dann aufgehört, weil er verletzt war, dann alle Jugendmannschaften trainiert, dann quasi die Profi-Mannschaft übernommen und dann natürlich so eine Saison mit Bayern aus dem DFB-Pokal rausgehauen. Religation am Ende. Ja, das ist für uns natürlich wirklich sehr, sehr schwer. Wir haben gehofft, dass er uns viele Jahre erhalten bleibt. Ich meine, wer weiß, vielleicht kommt er auch in irgendwelchen Jahren noch mal zurück. Aber eigentlich war das das perfekte Match. Und ja, für uns alle irgendwie so ein kleiner Schock, dass der jetzt ja geht.
Tja, manchmal ist das das perfekte Match. Du glaubst, es läuft ganz wunderbar und dann löst einfach jemand das Match auf. Aber wenn er am wenigsten noch eine solche Nachricht hinterlässt, dann hat man noch was, an dem man festhalten kann. Man wusste ja schon, dass es jetzt nicht so leicht werden würde, die vorherige Saison zu wiederholen, sowieso nicht, aber quasi auch auf einem ähnlichen Niveau weiterzumachen. Dafür waren einfach die Abgänge zu schwerwiegend. Jonas Meffert haben wir vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen. Yannis Serra ist da sicherlich noch zu nennen. Jason Lee ist zum 1. FSV Mainz 05 gewechselt. Wie findest du denn, hat das Holstein-Kiel bisher gemacht, jetzt auch mal unabhängig von dieser Trainerpersonalie?
Was war auf dem Platz zu beobachten? Offensiv, finde ich, sind wir immer noch... Also klar, wir sind nicht unbedingt effektiv, aber wir spielen uns weiterhin sehr viele Chancen raus. Ich spiele vorne eigentlich einen guten Ball, finde ich. Janisera zu ersetzen, klar, ist schwer, gerade weil er nach diesem ganzen Corona hin und her noch mal zur Höchstleistung aufgelaufen ist und uns sehr viele Tore beschert hat, dann tut so ein Abgang natürlich immer noch sehr weh. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, offensiv sind wir auf jeden Fall auch variabler als letzte Saison. Denn letzte Saison hatten wir eigentlich nur Janisera als Stürmer. Ja, im Mittelfeld, würde ich sagen, ist Meffert war nicht zu ersetzen. Das ist klar. Da haben wir dann einen Errers geholt von Werder Bremen, der überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat bisher. Und ja, einen Marcel Bänger von der zweiten, von Gladbach, der dann reingeworfen wurde und der seine Sache, finde ich, ganz gut macht. Defensiv ist er noch ein bisschen wackelig, aber gerade sein Spielaufbau und seine Pässe sind richtig gut. Ja, und defensiv tatsächlich, wo eigentlich am wenigsten passiert ist, ist diese Saison aber gefühlt trotzdem das Meiste passiert. Denn letzte Saison mit die beste Abwehr der Liga sind wir jetzt quasi mit die schlechteste Abwehr der Liga. Obwohl bis auf Janek Dem die gleichen Spieler sind. Und auch Neumann hat letzte Saison ja schon hin und wieder gespielt. Das ist noch so ein bisschen unerklärlich für mich. Hauke Wal, diese Saison sehr unsicher. Letzte Saison einer der besten Innenverteidiger der Liga. Thieska ist jetzt endlich wieder fit, hat gegen Paderborn jetzt endlich mal wieder gespielt. Da haben wir auch gewonnen, aber trotzdem ja. Defensiv ist irgendwie der Wurm drin bei uns. Warum, kann man auch nicht genau sagen. Es wirkt alles so ein bisschen verunsichert. Man weiß natürlich auch nicht, inwieweit der Verein oder die Mannschaft schon so mit dieser ganzen Ole-Werner-Sache vielleicht schon wusste. Und dann kommst du in so einen Negativstrudel, also sehr verunsichert. Aber das Potenzial, da rauszukommen und die Qualität, da rauszukommen, ist definitiv vorhanden, ja.
Wer wird denn der Nachfolger von Ole-Werner? Gibt es da schon Entscheidungen? Also ich hatte jetzt ein bisschen gelesen, Kohfeldt, Gorcinski, Thun, ist jetzt nicht so mega kreativ, alles, was irgendwie mal im Norden trainiert hat, dann auch gleich noch ein bisschen weiter nach Norden zu schieben.
Er hat schon mal eine Fischsammel gebissen, ein Fischbrötchen.
So ungefähr sah das aus. Also der Bremser, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, der macht das ja gerade, der darf aber auch nicht so lange, weil er keine Lizenz dafür hat. Dafür ist irgendwie eine Übergangsphase, 15 Werktage. Wie geht es zu Ende? Hast du schon einen Einblick?
Ja, also die Namen, die dann natürlich durch den Raum fliegen, sind natürlich immer groß und viel. Wie du sagst, Kohfeldt, wobei ich mir das nicht vorstellen kann, Tune, kann ich mir schon eher vorstellen. Finde ich von seiner Art, dass er auch passt. Ja, Kauschitzky wäre die klassische Uwe-Stöver-Lösung. Wäre ich jetzt aber auch kein Fan von, dann ist ja sogar schon Miroslav Klose als Name gefallen, der ja gerne mal als Profi-Trainer durchstarten möchte. Ja, also Namen gibt es viele, aber irgendwie, was sich wirklich bisher verdichtet hat oder wo man sagen könnte, ja, das könnte es werden, gibt es nicht. Also da sind wir alle ratlos.
Und was glaubst du, in welche Richtung wird es gehen? Weil die Trainer waren ja durchaus namhaft, spätestens nachdem sie bei Holstein waren, waren sie namhaft. Da habt ihr ja schon einen ganz guten Track-Record.
Genau, also das ist auch so ein bisschen das Ding. Viele sagen zum Beispiel, als der Name Klose fiel, ja, nee, wir brauchen einen erfahrenen Trainer oder der uns da rausholen kann oder jemand, der schon mal gezeigt hat, dass er was kann. Ich sag dann halt immer, ja, Markus Anfang und Tim Walter kannte in Anführungsstrichen auch keiner vor Holstein. Kiel, klar, Tim Walter war noch ein größerer Name schon, aber die sind ja auch erst bei uns richtig durchgestartet und beide haben wirklich exzellent bei uns funktioniert. Deswegen wäre das für mich jetzt kein Ausschlusskriterium, einen Trainer zu holen, der bisher nur eine Jugendmannschaft trainiert hat. Im Gespräch war ja auch Gunkel, ist unser U23-Trainer, der auch eine sehr, sehr gute Saison spielt. Damit hätte ich bei Kiel keine Bauchschmerzen, da hatte Kiel bisher immer Glück. Er mit so einem Namen, Schubert, hat nicht funktioniert. Ganz damals noch Falco Götz, noch als großen Namen in die Regionalliga geholt. Das hat auch überhaupt nicht funktioniert, genau wie Christian Wück danach auch überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Also lieber ein Trainer, der in Ruhe arbeiten kann.
Okay, also Falco Götz, ich musste nachgucken, das war ja 2009.
Ich dachte nur, so war es. Ja, das war so damals. Auf Platz 1 haben wir ganz logisch unseren Trainer entlassen, um dann den großen Namen Falco Götz zu holen, um dann durch zu starten. Da hieß es ja immer noch damals der Hoffenheim des Nordens und so. Und damit sind wir ja mächtig auf die Fresse gefallen.
Um dann mal aufs Sportliche zurückzukommen, wo wir nicht so sehr im Trüben fischen müssen. Du hast es ja auch schon angesprochen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir vielleicht in 5, 10 Spieltagen komplett anders über Holstein sprechen, weil man schleppt hat auch diesen fürchterlichen Saisonstart mit sich herum. 0 zu 3 beim FC St. Pauli, 0 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Schalke 04. Im DFB-Pokal zwar weitergekommen, aber nach Verlängerung beim SC Weiche 08 und dann 0 zu 3 gegen Jan Regensburg. Also zack, 0 zu 9 Tore nach drei Spieltagen. Danach schien es sich für mich als Außenstehenden schon stabilisiert zu haben. Es gab zwar nochmal eine Niederlage, natürlich auch wieder mit 0 zu 3. Das scheint das neue Go-To-Ergebnis zu sein. Und gegen Hannover 96, da hatten schon andere in dieser Saison keine Chance. Wer genau aufgepasst hat, weiß, welch Mannschaft ich damit meine.
Das war aber auch ein Freakspiel, muss man dazu sagen. Also mit Rot nach 10 Minuten und so. Da haben wir ein bisschen Glück gehabt in Kiel, möchte ich gerne anerkennen.
Das ist natürlich völlig korrekt. Aber es schien mir so zu sein, Pike, als hätte sich eben Holstein stabilisiert. Also es gab dann zwei 2-2-2-Spiele gegen Düsseldorf und Karlsruhe. Es gab den Sieg gegen Aue, jetzt den Sieg in Paderborn, den ich persönlich nicht erwartet habe. Aber gut, was kann man schon erwarten in dieser zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga? Also es schien sicher stabilisiert zu haben.
Ja, eigentlich dachte ich das sogar schon nach dem Schalke-Spiel, denn das Ergebnis ließ sich schlimmer als es war. Da waren wir einfach unfassbar ineffektiv, aber wir hatten 24 zu 9 Torschüsse auf Kiel's Seite, Passquote 90 Prozent zu 80 Prozent, wir hatten 63 Prozent Ballbesitz. Also eigentlich sprach alles für uns, außer unsere Abwehr und Simon Thurodde, weil den haben wir da wirklich auch komplett alleine gelassen.
Klar, den kattet ihr noch nicht, da ist in der zweiten Liga noch ein unbeschriebenes Blatt.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird noch mal einer. Sollte man auf dem Auge beiten. Das Regensburg-Spiel war dann natürlich direkt wieder ernüchternd. 3-0, wobei man natürlich jetzt auch sagen muss, gegen Regensburg kann man anscheinend mal verlieren. Die Mannspieler spielen ja wirklich eine überragende Saison. Ja, dann das Düsseldorf-Spiel, eigentlich 3 Punkte, am Ende noch knapp den Ausgleich kassiert. 3-0-Sieg gegen Aue, war ein gutes Spiel von Kiel. Allerdings muss man auch sagen, es ist nur Aue. Und auch, sorry, wenn man es so sagen muss, die spielen einen grauenvollen Fußball diese Saison. Karlsruhe auch, hätte man gewinnen können, wieder durch doofe Fehler das 2-2 kassiert. Das 3-0 gegen Hannover, ein Spiel, finde ich, was man ein bisschen ausgrenzen muss von allem. Weil einerseits klar, die frühe rote Karte, selbst wenn man dann noch was versuchen würde, dann geht so ein abgefälschter Schuss noch rein, ein paar Minuten später. Also da läuft wirklich alles gegen einen. Und dann ist es natürlich superschwer, gerade wenn du unten drin stehst. Und jetzt endlich mal wieder ein Sieg gegen Paderborn, die zwar auch einer weniger waren, die wir dann aber auch eingeladen haben zum Gegentor durch einen katastrophalen Fehlpass von Finn Bartels. Zum Glück noch gedreht. Ich glaube, hätten wir das verloren, hätte der Baum auf jeden Fall gebrannt hier in Kiel. Aber so war das jetzt, glaube ich, für die Mannschaft, fürs Umfeld und auch für die Fans ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Sieg, um alles so ein bisschen runterzufahren.
Und wo, glaubst du, ist die Ziellinie für Holstein Kiel? In welcher Tabellenregion muss man eigentlich dem, was man hat, an Spielern und an Möglichkeiten einlaufen in dieser Zweitliga-Saison?
Ja, also ich bin da ja immer noch relativ demütig und sage, nach so einem Saisonstart plus dieser ganzen Ole-Werner-Sache, mit einem Klassenerhalt bin ich zufrieden. Das ist so mein großer Wunsch. Aber wenn wir am Ende irgendwie, glaube ich, so 8. oder 9. oder 10., was ich nicht für unbedingt unrealistisch halte, dann bin ich auf jeden Fall zufrieden.
Und das kann ja auch sehr schnell gehen. In der zweiten Bundesliga der Männer haben wir schon häufig genug erlebt. Und die Saison ist ja dann noch sehr jung. Aber Holstein, Kiel, da sind wir mal sehr gespannt, wie das in der Trainer-Sache weitergeht. Eine Mannschaft gibt es noch, über die wir sprechen wollen. Das ist der SV Sandhausen. Der liegt aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 16 und wurde bisher noch nicht besprochen im Rasenfunk. Zwei Siege, ein Unentschieden, fünf Niederlagen. Da schien es Tobi ganz, ganz schlimm loszugehen und wurde jetzt dann ein bisschen besser, wenn man sich das anguckt. Also unter anderem der letzte Sieg war da jetzt natürlich wichtig. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, gegen wen hat Sandhausen gespielt.
Hannover 96 ist mir völlig unbekannt, die Mannschaft. Keine Ahnung.
Also wir haben es ja vorhin schon angesprochen. Da haben auch individuelle Fehler eine Rolle gespielt. Aber jetzt hattest du eben so einen so genauen Blick auf den SVS. Wie schätzt du die denn bisher ein?
Na doll fand ich sie nicht, muss ich ehrlich gestehen. Also in der ersten Halbzeit kam gar nichts von Sandhausen, hatte ich das Gefühl. Die hatten auch kein Interesse daran, irgendwie was zum Spiel beizutragen.
Ja, 31 Prozent Ballbesitz, ja.
Ja, also es war wirklich, macht ihr mal und ihr werdet schon irgendwann was Dummes machen. Mit der Einstellung sind sie da rangegangen, hat natürlich auch funktioniert, ärgerlicherweise. Zweite Halbzeit hat Hannover dann auch nicht mehr so viel gemacht und dann kam aber auch nichts von Sandhausen, hatte ich das Gefühl. Also spielerisch war das wirklich, das war wenig. Also die vorne liefen glaube ich Kate Deruehl rum und Charlie Benchop, was dann schon mit zwei Stürmern fast schon beeindruckend war, aber die haben halt auch nichts zum Spiel beigetragen oder sich Chancen ausgearbeitet. Also man wusste schon, warum die da stehen, wo sie stehen in der Tabelle und der einzige Sieg, den sie vor dem Sieg gegen Hannover 96 hatten, war halt auch gegen Erzgebirge Aue. Also auch das sagt dann natürlich schon irgendwie aus, wie diese Saison im Moment bei ihnen läuft. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, das ist nicht beeindruckend. Das nächste Spiel ist gegen Darmstadt, über die haben wir vorhin auch schon gesprochen. Das ist wieder so ein Ding, wo hinterher dann alle sagen, ach ja, Mensch, guck, jetzt haben sie gegen Darmstadt auch gewonnen. Und jetzt haben sie dann schon ihre 10 Punkte zusammen und sind da unten rausgeklettert, weil sie ja auch, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, den Trainer gewechselt haben oder beziehungsweise die Trainer, Kleppinger und Kulowicz, haben das ja zusammen gemacht. Die haben sie dann rausgeschmissen nach dem siebten Spieltag, natürlich vor dem Spiel gegen Hannover 96, damit dann der neue, altbekannte Trainer Alois Schwarz gleich mit einem Sieg starten kann. Super Geschichte, ist ganz, ganz toll mit Sandhausen dieses Jahr.
Also Alois Schwarz war schon von 2013 bis 2016 Trainer beim SVS 108 Spiele, stand er an der Seitenlinie, ist eigentlich derjenige, mit dem meisten Spielen, nach ihm dann Kenan Kocsak und Uwe Koschinath. Das sind, glaube ich, die Namen, die wir alle auch noch so, zumindest so dunkel im Gedächtnis haben bei Sandhausen. Pike, was ist dein Eindruck vom SVS? Es scheint ja, also wird eine Zähl-Saison, ist jetzt aber nicht so die komplett spannende Vorhersage bei Sandhausen.
Genau. Ja, ich fand immer noch, dass die Entlassung von Koschinath damals irgendwie ein Fehler war. Das hat halt irgendwie gepasst und der hat echt eigentlich immer das Beste aus Sandhausen rausgeholt. Ich finde, eigentlich der Kader von Sandhausen ist gar nicht so verkehrt. Also allgemein Sandhausen immer mal mit Transfers, wo man sagt, wie machen sie das eigentlich? Also jetzt einen Pascal Teströhrt von Aue geholt, einen Ritzmeier von Barnsley, Gaudinho von den Young Boys Bern, der ja auch bei vielen Vereinen irgendwie auf dem Zettel stand. Also die haben öfter mal Transfers, wo man sagt, okay, warum geht der Spieler jetzt zum Sandhausen? Finde ich immer ganz spannend, deren Transferphasen. Aber spielerisch, ja, ich will nicht sagen, da fehlt ihnen die Mittel, weil die haben sie gefühlt eigentlich. Aber offensiv sind sie halt auch nicht kreativ. Also sie haben halt, ja, eine Ruelle und jetzt ein Band-Shop, da weiß man halt auch, was man da kriegt, wenn man die da vorne stehen hat. Gut, ein Test-Rid noch, der ein bisschen kreativer ist, aber an sich alles drei diese klassischen Abschlussstürmer aktuell. Also auch jetzt nicht schwer zu verteidigen, glaube ich, wenn man da so ein bisschen das System raus hat. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Problem, dass ihnen da so die offensiven Lösungen fehlen. Ansonsten finde ich, ja, Sandhausen könnte weiter oben stehen, auf jeden Fall vom Potenzial, aber das rufen sie halt nicht konstant ab.
Gut, dann lassen wir es dabei auch bewenden und blicken auf Sandhausen mal irgendwann anders. Genauer, es sei noch der Vollständigkeit halber erwähnt, dass wir noch weitere Trainer-Entlassungen bzw. Trainerwechsel in der zweiten Liga haben. Ingolstadt, da wurde sowohl Trainer Roberto Petzold als auch der technische Direktor Florian Zehe entlassen. Vor dem Schalke-Spiel war das schon bekannt geworden. Und auch Aue hat sich in einer typischen Erzgebirge-Aue-Art von Spielewski getrennt. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr eine Meinung zu diesen frühen Trainerwechseln, Tobi, in Anführungszeichen, aber die Art und Weise, wie das kommuniziert wurde?
Ich müsste lügen, wenn mir das nicht bekannt vorkommen würde. Aber das insbesondere mit Aue, ich gehe mal davon aus, du spielst darauf so ein bisschen an, war schon, ich hatte das Spiel irgendwie im Vorbericht gesehen, wo der Präsident sich dann geäußert hatte. Und nach dem Spiel war es dann schneller vorbei, als man gucken konnte. Insgesamt ein bisschen unangenehm, das Ganze zu betrachten von außen, ja.
Also so direkt mit Schlusspfiff sinngemäß war dann die Entscheidung nicht nur intern, sondern auch extern verkündet. Ich glaube, das ist das größte Problem, dass man das dann einfach direkt nach einem Spiel macht. Pike, hast du einen Take dazu?
Ja, also den Präsidenten von Aue, den kennt man ja nun schon durch seine Aktion, eine sehr spannende Personalie. Sportlich, muss ich sagen, bei Sandhausen konnte ich es nicht unbedingt verstehen, weil wie gesagt, da ist ja wirklich noch alles drin. Ehe so früh noch in der Saison, alles sehr eng. Bei Aue muss ich wirklich sagen, kann ich es verstehen, weil der Fußball wirklich, wirklich schlecht und nicht zweitligereif war. Muss man leider knallhart so sagen. Und deswegen kann ich es da verstehen, dass da die Reißleine gezogen wurde. Wie ihr schon sagtet, wie es kommuniziert wurde, das kann man, glaube ich, unkommentiert stehen lassen. Das spricht für sich.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Zu Ingolstadt habe ich noch ein Zitat rausgesucht von Peter Jeckwert, dem Vereinschef von Ingolstadt. Er sagt zu der Entlassung, wir hatten irgendwann das Gefühl, irgendetwas stimmt nicht, trotz der drei bösen Klatschen gegen Darmstadt, Bremen und St. Pauli. Hatten wir die Hoffnung, dass wir das Heimspiel gegen Düsseldorf positiv gestalten können. Nach dem 0 zu 1 gingen die Köpfe runter und es kam keine Reaktion mehr. Danach hatten wir das Gefühl, einen neuen Impuls setzen zu müssen. Und wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche anderen Namen genannt hätte, hätte man das auf jede andere Entlassung setzen können. Das ist einfach das kleine One-on-one, warum habt ihr euren Trainer entlassen? Und auf die Antwort, warum sie André Schubert geholt, hatte er dann auch die Antwort auf die Frage, warum André Schubert, ja, ich habe seit 2005 mit ihm Kontakt und der Kontakt ist nie abgerissen. Gut, so läuft es halt auch noch im deutschen Profifußball.
Hatte er bei uns damals schon Ingolstadt im Kopf, deswegen lief es bei uns nicht.
Ja, das ist ja, das ging ja schon so vielen Trainern so, dass sie einfach schon Ingolstadt im Kopf, dann verliert man es. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch ganz herzlich für diesen Parforce-Ritt durch die 2. Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer. Ich kann nur sehr alle Podcasts empfehlen, die ihr sonst noch so tut und euch auf Twitter zu folgen. Pike von 1912fm als 1912fm-Kiel auch auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du mal im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich zu hören. Und Tobias Rieger, der Ad-Runner, Tobi, auf Twitter hört natürlich die MeinSportPodcast-WG sehr empfehlenswert. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für dieses schnöde Fußballprojekt hier. Das ist ja eigentlich viel zu wenig für dich, für das, was du kannst.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das war sehr, sehr schön. Vielen Dank für die Einladung, Max.
Schön, dass du mit dabei warst. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Auch dieses Format finanziert sich allein durch euch. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die das tun. Dann hören wir uns wieder in einem der nächsten Rasenfunk-Formate. Das nächste Datumstechnisch ist eine Schlusskonferenz zum nächsten Erstligaspieltag. Bis dahin macht's gut, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf.